The hat is back! I'm so excited that the hat is back. I know, my hair is amazing. So Connor usually wears a hat, like when, recorded on May 19th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we interview Sean Parent for the second time. This is part one of our two-part interview with him, where we talk about slide decks, UI, and so much more. Have you fixed your audio setup so that you're no longer recording in a closet? No, man. You haven't listened to the last episode, but my audio has never been crispier. It is so crispy. So you're in the closet, aren't you?
帽子又回来了！我太激动了，帽子又回来了。我知道，我的头发很棒。Connor通常会戴帽子，比如在2021年5月19日录制的时候。我是Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人Bryce一起，第二次采访Sean Parent。这是我们对他两部分采访的第一部分，我们谈论了幻灯片、用户界面等等。你修好你的音频设备了吗，这样你就不用在衣柜里录音了？没有，伙计。你没听上一集，但我的音频从来没有这么清晰过。它非常清晰。所以你还在衣柜里，对吧？
Yeah. We're doing a little experiment today because I have acquired two chairs. So now I have three chairs. And the chairs that I have, I got, I mentioned before, I got from my sister. And this one is not like a desk chair though, so it doesn't have any cushion
是的。我们今天在做一个小实验，因为我弄到了两把椅子。所以现在我有三把椅子了。我之前提到过，这些椅子是我从我姐姐那里拿来的。不过这把椅子不像办公椅，所以它没有任何垫子
or fabric on it. It's just like a lightweight, I don't know, sort of party chair. And we'll see. Maybe I'll have to revert back to the office chair if my audio is not as crispy anymore because fabric equals less echo. I'm like, I'm on my way to becoming an audiophile. I was about to say, you're such an audiophile i was about to say you're such an audiophile nerd except it's so sad because like i'm where i have these like a hundred dollar sports uh bows like uh running headphones that i'm using wait was that was that supposed to be that those headphones are not impressive enough no yeah like an audiophile would have some $700, you know, with some special cables and stuff that I don't know about.
或者织物。它就像一把轻便的，我不知道，某种派对椅。我们走着瞧吧。如果我的音频不再那么清晰，也许我得换回办公椅，因为织物意味着更少的回声。我感觉，我正在成为发烧友的路上。我正想说，你真是个发烧友，我正想说你真是个发烧友书呆子，除了这很可悲，因为我用的是那种一百美元的Bose运动耳机，等等，那是说那些耳机不够令人印象深刻吗？不，是的，发烧友会用那种700美元的，你知道，带一些我不知道的特殊线材之类的东西。
But you realize that it's pretty privileged that you just said, oh, yeah, I only have these $100 Bose headphones. I don't have the $700 headphones. Yeah, my bad. I should check my privilege. But if you can if you can see like the little plastic casing around the wires is all like torn up and I'm about to electrocute myself one of these days. Audience, these these headphones are not in good shape. I'm actually I'm I'm very excited because since we last talked, Sean has submitted his committee paper on moved from objects, which we just scheduled last week. Yeah, yeah. Scheduled for out in August, which seems like a long time.
但你意识到你刚才说“哦，是的，我只有这些100美元的Bose耳机，我没有700美元的耳机”是相当有特权的吗？是的，我的错。我应该反思一下我的特权。但如果你能看到电线周围的小塑料外壳都撕裂了，我哪天可能会电到自己。观众们，这些耳机状况不太好。我其实非常兴奋，因为自从我们上次交谈以来，Sean已经提交了他的关于移动对象的委员会论文，我们上周刚刚安排了讨论。是的，是的。安排在八月，这看起来是很久以后的事了。
But yes, unfortunately, unfortunately, with with how our schedule during the pandemic is, August is the first time chance that we'll get to look at it. But I'm excited for it. It's it's it's probably been a few years since've, you've been in a C++ committee meeting or. Yeah, it's, it's been quite a while. This came about because, uh, John Lakos approached me at ACCU virtually and he's working on his new book. And he said that he knew that I had an annoyance with move semantics and wanted me to write something up on it. So I wrote about three pages for his book. And then he suggested, he said, you know, this would be a better three pages if it could reference a standards proposal to fix it. So I wrote the standards proposal to fix it. See, you got nerd sniped. That is a pro
但是的，不幸的是，不幸的是，考虑到我们在疫情期间的时间表，八月是我们第一次有机会审视它。但我对此很兴奋。你可能已经有几年没有参加C++委员会会议了，或者……是的，已经有相当长一段时间了。这是因为John Lakos在ACCU虚拟会议上找到我，他正在写他的新书。他说他知道我对移动语义有意见，想让我写点关于它的东西。所以我为他的书写了大约三页。然后他建议说，你知道，如果能引用一个标准提案来修复它，这三页会更好。所以我写了修复它的标准提案。看，你被书呆子陷阱了。这是一个专业的
Lakos move to get somebody to write a paper. Yeah. Lakos is a notorious manipulator. I assume that both of you have seen John Lakos give a talk. I love how that man gives a talk. And I, in particular, I really appreciate how he makes a slide deck. Because he does it the same way that I do, where I don't put any transitions into my slides, but instead I'll have multiple slides that, if I wanted to have a slide with transition, I'll have a few different slides,
Lakos式举动，让别人写论文。是的，Lakos是个臭名昭著的操纵者。我假设你们俩都看过John Lakos的演讲。我喜欢那个人演讲的方式。而且，我特别欣赏他制作幻灯片的方式。因为他和我做的方式一样，我不给幻灯片加任何转场，而是会有多张幻灯片，如果我想让幻灯片有转场，我会用几张不同的幻灯片，
each one that adds another element to the last slide. And I don't really know why i do that i guess it's just like uh i feel like it gives me a little bit more control in it and then it exports to pdf better um uh but uh so so as a result of this john lakos will come to give an hour-long talk and he'll be like oh yeah i've got I've got 800 slides. Yeah. Yeah. Every time I'm working on a slide deck, I have to resist the urge of writing my own slide deck engine because I can't find a tool that does what I want. Yeah, I think I recall I asked you once in your C++ seasoning talk how you did the really nice, like, sliding code up the screen. And I was expecting, oh, it's going to be something super fancy,
每一张都在上一张的基础上增加一个元素。我真的不知道我为什么要这样做，我想这只是因为我觉得它给了我更多的控制权，而且导出为PDF效果更好。嗯，所以结果就是，John Lakos会来做一个一小时的演讲，他会说，哦，是的，我有800张幻灯片。是的，是的。每次我制作幻灯片时，我都必须抵制编写自己的幻灯片引擎的冲动，因为我找不到一个能满足我需求的工具。是的，我想我记得有一次在你的C++ Seasoning演讲中问过你，你是怎么做出那种非常漂亮的、代码在屏幕上滑动的效果的。我当时以为，哦，那肯定是非常高级的，
but you basically did it like the classic, I think, like just big images, and then you, like, move it up the screen, and then it looks like it's sliding. But it's done so, like, flawlessly that I thought for sure you had some, like, custom Adobe, like, unreleased keynote or PowerPoint. No, no, that was done painfully and manually in keynote. So yeah, yeah. I would, there's not many things
但你基本上是用经典的方法做的，我想，就像大图片，然后你让它在屏幕上移动，看起来就像在滑动。但它做得如此完美，以至于我肯定以为你用了某种定制的Adobe，或者未发布的Keynote或PowerPoint。不，不，那是痛苦地在Keynote中手动完成的。所以是的，是的。没有多少事情
that I would like really believe and invest in, but if Sean Parent wanted to make a slide engine, that I would get on board with. It's funny how many times there's been at least like a handful of slide decks or presentations that I've seen. I can remember one too. Sean M. I'm going to forget his last name.
是我会真正相信并投入其中的，但如果Sean Parent想做一个幻灯片引擎，我会加入。有趣的是，我见过至少几手幻灯片或演示文稿。我也能记得一个。Sean M. 我要忘记他的姓了。
He works at Google. And he did a talk on coroutines and Kotlin. And he did this like little history of coroutines. And it was like zoom in, zoom out, all this just amazing. And I thought he must be using Prezi, must be using something. And then I went and asked him after. And he was was like no i just a bunch of images it's very you know very painful and i'm like why we got all these beautiful presentations and we haven't figured out how to make it uh easy for slide deck people you know i i used reveal so i usually use
他在谷歌工作。他做了一个关于协程和Kotlin的演讲。他做了这个关于协程的小历史。就像放大、缩小，所有这些都太棒了。我以为他一定是在用Prezi，一定是在用什么东西。然后我事后问他。他说不，我只是一堆图片，非常，你知道，非常痛苦。我说为什么我们有这么多漂亮的演示文稿，却还没弄清楚如何让它对幻灯片制作人员来说变得容易，你知道，我用了Reveal，所以我通常用
powerpoint for my slides one time for my 2017 uh talk that was like an intro, it was called C++ 17 Features. It was an introduction to like, you know, every C++ 17 Features. For that talk, I decided I'm going to try the new cool thing and try using reveal.js, which is like a slide framework where you write your slides in like markdown and you know you put them in a github repo and they get compiled to you know html and javascript um it's what all the cool kids use and i tried it and the you know the main reason that i wanted to use it was testability of my sample code you know i wanted to be able to write the code in a way where I could compile like all my example code locally and then have that
PowerPoint做我的幻灯片，有一次为了我2017年的演讲，那是一个介绍，叫做C++ 17特性。那是对，你知道，每一个C++ 17特性的介绍。对于那个演讲，我决定尝试一下新的酷东西，尝试使用reveal.js，它是一个幻灯片框架，你在其中用Markdown编写幻灯片，你知道，你把它们放在一个GitHub仓库里，它们会被编译成，你知道，HTML和JavaScript。这是所有酷孩子都在用的，我试了一下，你知道，我想用它的主要原因是我的示例代码的可测试性，你知道，我想以一种我可以本地编译所有示例代码的方式编写代码，然后让它
be imported into the slides so that I could unit test all my example code in the slides because every talk that I'd give some person would afterwards come up to me and say, aha you had a typo on this line. You had a typo on that line. I wanted to avoid that. And so I did the presentation and it was like, I'm not saying it was a bad experience, but it was just like, not for me. Because the problem was that when I needed, when I wanted to go and like change where something was on the screen. You know, I couldn't just go do that. I needed to go into the file and like edit something and like edit a location. Whereas what I wanted to do was like visually move a thing.
被导入到幻灯片中，这样我就可以对幻灯片中的所有示例代码进行单元测试，因为我每次演讲，之后都会有人走过来对我说，啊，你这一行有个错别字。你那一行有个错别字。我想避免这种情况。所以我做了那个演示，我不是说那是一次糟糕的经历，但它只是，不适合我。因为问题在于，当我想去改变屏幕上某样东西的位置时。你知道，我不能直接那样做。我需要进入文件，编辑一些东西，编辑一个位置。而我想做的是像视觉上移动一个东西。
And at that point in my career, I was like, you know, the person who was like, I just want a Vim interface to everything. Like I want to do everything in the command line. You know, GUIs are for suckers. I don't want to use a GUI for anything. And that, and like, I, you know, of course, like I'm going to use Linux for everything. I'm just going to, my interface to the world is a Linux command line interface. And that was the moment when I like first came to really appreciate the power of a good graphical interface because like for making a slide I wanted to be able to
在那一刻，我的职业生涯中，我就像，你知道，那个说“我只想要一个Vim界面来处理一切”的人。就像我想在命令行里做所有事情。你知道，GUI是给傻瓜用的。我不想用GUI做任何事情。而且，就像，我，你知道，当然，我要用Linux做一切。我只是，我与世界的接口就是Linux命令行界面。那一刻，我第一次真正体会到了一个好的图形界面的力量，因为制作幻灯片时，我希望能够
like visually see it and like move it around and then be like yeah that looks that looks that looks pretty good it looks pretty good and like after that I have increasingly I've increasingly like spent more of my time thinking about like like, you know, is this a task that I want the, sort of, the efficiency gains that I might get from something that's purely textual, or do I want, you know, I want a graphical interface to this thing, because it's something that I really need to visualize and, like, visually see. Yeah, when I'm teaching classes or just developing a new slide deck, I use Jupyter Notebook, which is usually a data science thing and associated with Python.
视觉上看到它，移动它，然后说“是的，看起来不错，看起来不错”。在那之后，我越来越多地花时间思考，比如，你知道，这是一个我想要那种纯文本可能带来的效率提升的任务，还是我想要，你知道，我想要一个图形界面来处理这个东西，因为它是我真正需要可视化和视觉上看到的东西。是的，当我教课或只是开发一个新的幻灯片时，我使用Jupyter Notebook，它通常是数据科学的东西，与Python相关。
But it's got support through something called Zeus Cling to let you put interpreted C++ 17 embedded directly in your notebook and it's executable and and the notebook can output to reveal.js and so I can build up my whole slide deck with all of my code and all of my code is executable and you can see the results directly on the slides and I can go change the code and and edit it and and figure out the right order to structure things so that, you know, so as the user's going through the slides, they see all the pieces that come together. But controlling the output of it is painful enough that, you know, it's fine if I'm teaching a course
但它通过一种叫做Zeus Cling的东西提供支持，让你把解释型的C++ 17直接嵌入到你的笔记本中，它是可执行的，笔记本可以输出到reveal.js，所以我可以用我所有的代码构建我的整个幻灯片，我所有的代码都是可执行的，你可以直接在幻灯片上看到结果，我可以去修改代码，编辑它，找出结构化的正确顺序，这样，你知道，当用户浏览幻灯片时，他们能看到所有拼凑在一起的部分。但控制它的输出足够痛苦，你知道，如果我是在教一门课，那没关系
and it's just like the equivalent of a whiteboard. But if I'm going to do a keynote presentation or something, then that's my draft. And then I'll sit down and keynote and make it pretty. I do want to take this opportunity to plug a PowerPoint plug-in that I recently purchased and have used, which has been been transformative which is it's called PowerPoint Shortcut Tools and it is super awesome. It makes it so much quicker for me to build my
它就像白板的等价物。但如果我要做一个主题演讲之类的，那只是我的草稿。然后我会坐下来用Keynote把它做得漂亮。我想借此机会推荐一个我最近购买并使用过的PowerPoint插件，它具有变革性，叫做PowerPoint Shortcut Tools，它超级棒。它让我构建我的
PowerPoint decks because it's got a whole bunch of very useful key bindings and macros. I've got a collection of scripts for Keynote that I've written over the years that probably do some of the equivalent things. It's like, you hit one button and... That's awesome.
PowerPoint幻灯片快多了，因为它有一大堆非常有用的快捷键和宏。我多年来为Keynote写了一系列脚本，可能做了一些等效的事情。就像，你按一个按钮，然后……太棒了。
You would. I've thought about learning how to. I learned once, because Excel macros are a big thing, and I got into that when I was younger. And then I'd heard about Access. That's Microsoft Access, like the database, not any other word that you might have confused what I just said about access that's Microsoft access like the database not any other word that you might have confused what I just said with it's a terrible name there's access VBA like macro programming but I looked into to see like I think the most useful at this point of my life would be like a PowerPoint like little scripting language but when I looked into that I
你会的。我考虑过学习如何做。我学过一次，因为Excel宏是一件大事，我年轻时就接触过。然后我听说过Access。那是Microsoft Access，就像数据库，而不是你可能混淆我刚才说的关于access的其他任何词，那是Microsoft Access，就像数据库，而不是你可能混淆我刚才说的其他任何词，这是一个糟糕的名字，有Access VBA，比如宏编程，但我研究了一下，看看，我想我生命中这个阶段最有用的会是像PowerPoint那样的小脚本语言，但当我研究那个时，我
just found a YouTube video of someone building like a Turing machine and PowerPoint and doing some crazy things, which which I can link that in the show notes if anyone's ever wondering, because this is probably the number one question I get asked is how do I do my little code animations? It's a transition called morph. I think keynote has the same thing called magic or something like that. And yeah, you just you have to change the mode to words instead of objects. And then it figures everything out. It's an amazing algorithm. And I'm, I'm very sad that I tried to mimic that stuff, uh, in pre Microsoft PowerPoint 2019, cause it was just so much work, but. No, I, I got one more thought on this,
只是在YouTube上发现有人在PowerPoint中构建了一个图灵机，做了一些疯狂的事情，我可以把那个链接放在节目说明里，如果有人想知道的话，因为这可能是我被问到的第一个问题，就是我怎么做我的小代码动画？那是一个叫做Morph的转场。我想Keynote也有同样的东西，叫做Magic之类的。是的，你只需要把模式改为单词而不是对象。然后它就能算出一切。这是一个了不起的算法。而且，我很遗憾我试图在Microsoft PowerPoint 2019之前模仿那些东西，因为那真是太费力了，但是。不，我，我还有一个想法，
but then I got one more thought on this and then I got a good transition. Um, do you know what we're transitioning to though? No, I know what I'm transitioning to. I want to try. The reason that I invested in, the reason I bought a copy of shortcut tools was for copy object position, which is a really useful, you know, key binding to have like, hey, this thing's at this position on this slide. On this other slide, I want this thing at the same, I want a different object at the same position. And then, of course, like key bindings to align various different things. I drive my colleagues crazy because I'll look at their slide decks and I'll be like, that's not aligned, that's not aligned.
但我还有一个想法，然后我有一个好的转场。嗯，你知道我们要转场到什么吗？不，我知道我要转场到什么。我想试试。我投资的原因，我购买Shortcut Tools副本的原因是“复制对象位置”，这是一个非常有用的快捷键，比如，“嘿，这个东西在这个幻灯片上的这个位置。在另一个幻灯片上，我想要这个东西在相同的位置，我想要一个不同的对象在相同的位置”。然后，当然，还有对齐各种不同东西的快捷键。我让我的同事们抓狂，因为我会看他们的幻灯片，然后说，那个没对齐，那个没对齐。
Like, send me your PowerPoint. I'm going to go through and align all your things for you. But speaking, here's the transition. Wait for it. It's really, speaking of user transitions, I don't work on graphic user interfaces. And like, really, I solely work on like libraries in the back end. I don't really work in anything that has like, quote, civilian users. And so I never really thought much about user interface or graphical interface until I saw one of Sean Parent's more recent talks,
就像，把你的PowerPoint发给我。我要帮你把所有东西都对齐。但说到，这是转场。等着瞧。这真的，说到用户转场，我不做图形用户界面。而且，真的，我只在后端做库。我真的不做任何有，引用，“平民用户”的东西。所以我从来没怎么想过用户界面或图形界面，直到我看到了Sean Parent最近的一次演讲，
which I think was at CppCon in 2018 or 2019 on user interfaces. It was one of the better code talks. And for somebody who doesn't think about user interface, it made me care about user interface. I really loved that talk. Well, thank you. So I'm trying to think of,
我想是在2018年或2019年的CppCon上关于用户界面的。那是更好的代码演讲之一。对于一个不考虑用户界面的人来说，它让我关心用户界面。我真的很喜欢那个演讲。好吧，谢谢。所以我正在想，
because I've done a couple of talks that include user interface bits. It was the one where you had the slides about the user interface of a bathroom in a hotel in Germany that you stayed at from meeting C++. Yes, yes, okay. I think that's my relationships talk. Right. The relationships talk. Yes. Yes. That's what it was. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was really interesting to see how you think about that because it's a field that I've never even thought about before. Yeah. Yeah. And there's a section in it it which is near the bathroom section, which is going through possible user interfaces for just an implies relationship between two Booleans.
因为我做过几次包含用户界面片段的演讲。就是你展示了你在德国一家酒店住的浴室的用户界面的幻灯片，那是从Meeting C++来的。是的，是的，好的。我想那是我的关系演讲。对，关系演讲。是的。是的。就是那个。是的。是的。看到你是如何思考这个问题的非常有趣，因为这是一个我以前从未想过的领域。是的。是的。其中有一个部分，就在浴室部分附近，是浏览两个布尔值之间隐含关系的可能用户界面。
You know, A implies B. And all the different ways that that could be represented and all the tradeoffs in making that representation. And all the ways to get it wrong. And I send that little snippet out frequently when I'm working with designers because it's this problem area where every time a UI designer hits an implies relationship, and they're quite common in user interfaces, they basically start from a blank sheet and they're like, okay, so I've got this relationship where if I click on this then that needs to be true and they'll start with, okay, so
你知道，A蕴含B。以及所有可以表示它的不同方式，以及在做出这种表示时的所有权衡。以及所有弄错的方法。我经常在我与设计师合作时发送那个小片段，因为这是一个问题领域，每次UI设计师遇到隐含关系时，它们在用户界面中很常见，他们基本上从一张白纸开始，他们就像，好的，所以我有了这个关系，如果我点击这个，那么那个就需要是真的，他们会从，好的，所以
how should I represent that and what are the behaviors involved and I have these frequent arguments where I think the UI industry as an industry should really work on rule sets on like, okay, if we have an implies relationship under these circumstances, we're going to, to build it this way, under a different set of circumstances, maybe we'll take a different approach, but build up what the rule set is and document it well and establish standards for things like that. At Adobe, do you have, is there like a set of design principles for something like Photoshop for the UI for things like this? Yeah, we have a design team and a set of design principles that go around that. And, you know, a team of designers
我应该如何表示它，涉及哪些行为，我经常有这些争论，我认为UI行业作为一个行业真的应该致力于规则集，比如，好的，如果我们有隐含关系，在这些情况下，我们要以这种方式构建它，在不同的一组情况下，也许我们会采取不同的方法，但建立规则集是什么，并记录好它，并为类似的事情建立标准。在Adobe，你们有，比如有一套Photoshop之类的设计原则，针对这类事情的UI吗？是的，我们有一个设计团队和一套围绕它的设计原则。而且，你知道，一个设计师团队
that are trying to bring all of the Adobe applications to be more consistent, which is always a problem because Adobe grows largely through acquisition. So, you know, as soon as you think you're there, you've kind of sucked in a couple more products and you've got things to normalize. So we do have a team that works on that. My criticism of the team would be that they tend to be a little myopic,
试图让所有的Adobe应用程序更加一致，这总是一个问题，因为Adobe主要是通过收购来发展的。所以，你知道，一旦你认为你到了那里，你又吸收了几个产品，你就有东西需要标准化了。所以我们确实有一个团队在做这个。我对该团队的批评是，他们往往有点短视，
which is they tend to build the rules around individual features as opposed to building what we would call generic rules. Right, right, right. What things have that shape and build the rules around things that have that shape. So when you encounter a new problem, you can figure out, well, what are the attributes of this problem
也就是说，他们倾向于围绕单个功能构建规则，而不是构建我们所说的通用规则。对，对，对。什么东西有那种形状，并围绕有那种形状的东西构建规则。所以当你遇到一个新问题时，你可以弄清楚，好吧，这个问题的属性是什么
and what rules would apply to this and come up with a good design without invoking a designer and having them draw a bunch of pictures. That reminds me of a conversation that I had with, that I either had with Tony, or it was on the podcast with Tony at C++ Now, where Tony was talking about, he maintains this set of design principles at his company. And whenever he does a code review, if he sees something that he doesn't like, and there's not a design rule that covers it,
以及什么规则适用于此，并想出一个好的设计，而不需要调用设计师并让他们画一堆图。这让我想起了我与Tony进行的对话，或者是在C++ Now的播客上与Tony进行的对话，Tony谈到他在他的公司维护这套设计原则。每当他进行代码审查时，如果他看到他不喜欢的某些东西，并且没有设计规则涵盖它，
he goes and thinks up and writes a design rule for it and puts it into the guidelines. Yeah. Years ago, I wrote a layout engine. It's open sourced. It's known as EVE. It's part of Adobe Source Libraries. And it's a layout engine for UI. And it gets used heavily at Adobe.
他就会去思考并写出一个设计规则，并将其放入指南中。是的。几年前，我写了一个布局引擎。它是开源的。它被称为EVE。它是Adobe Source Libraries的一部分。它是UI的布局引擎。它在Adobe被大量使用。
In fact, almost all of Photoshop is laid out with Eve. And Eve has its own kind of baked-in rule sets for doing layout. And the rule sets came about because at the time I was working with a Photoshop designer, and I would, you know, this was years and years and years ago, so I would literally you know, this was years and years and years ago, so I would literally do this on paper. I would print out different variants of a UI and go to her and ask her which one she liked better. And she'd point at one and go, you know, this is the best one. And then I'd be like, why? Why do you say that? And, you know, the conversation would always start
事实上，几乎所有的Photoshop都是用Eve布局的。Eve有它自己内置的布局规则集。这些规则集之所以出现，是因为当时我正在和一位Photoshop设计师合作，我会，你知道，这是很多很多年前的事了，所以我真的，你知道，这是很多很多年前的事了，所以我真的会在纸上做这件事。我会打印出UI的不同变体，去找她，问她更喜欢哪一个。她会指着一个说，你知道，这是最好的一个。然后我会问，为什么？你为什么这么说？而且，你知道，对话总是开始
with, well, because it looks better. And it's like, not good enough, right? Right. And, you know, the conversation would always start with, well, because it looks better. And it's like, not good enough. Right? Right. And eventually you would uncover, you know, she had a very strong design sense. And she had internalized a bunch of design rules. And so you would just have to, you know, I would have to pull those out of her. It's like, well, it looks better because this over here is aligning with that over there. Right?
于，嗯，因为它看起来更好。就像，不够好，对吧？对。而且，你知道，对话总是开始于，嗯，因为它看起来更好。就像，不够好。对吧？对。最终你会发现，你知道，她有很强的设计感。她内化了一堆设计规则。所以你只需要，你知道，我必须把那些从她那里挖掘出来。就像，嗯，它看起来更好是因为这边的这个正在与那边的那个对齐。对吧？
And so then I would go and print a whole bunch of things where things aligned in that way. And she would go through and mark them up and be like, yeah, but this one's wrong. And I'd be like, okay okay why is that one wrong well because in this case you know this should really be aligning with this other thing because that's a stronger a stronger visual aspect and so so it was you know months of kind of working with her to to dig out her her design sense and encapsulate it into a set of rules and build that into the code i think it's interesting that you said like alignment there like three or four times because a lot of times people ask like oh you know what should i do to improve slide decks and stuff and
所以然后我会去打印一堆东西，让东西以那种方式对齐。她会检查它们并标记出来，就像，是的，但这个是错的。我会说，好的，好的，为什么那个是错的？嗯，因为在这种情况下，你知道，这真的应该与这另一个东西对齐，因为那是一个更强的视觉方面。所以，你知道，花了几个月的时间和她一起工作，挖掘出她的设计感，并将其封装成一套规则，并将其构建到代码中。我认为有趣的是，你刚才说了三四次“对齐”，因为很多时候人们问，比如，哦，你知道我应该做什么来改进幻灯片之类的，而且
like it really is just a set of like three or four simple rules and like two of the main things which i think bryce you mentioned came in your plug-in set are like the alignment you know top bottom left right and then also like the vertical and horizontal spacing like small things like that if you have i think we've even talked about this the last time you were on where you have like you know five bullet points and one of the bullet points is got like an extra half line spacing in it than the other ones like that's not symmetric i think our eyes are drawn to like symmetry because it's it's pattern recognition it's easier for our brains to oh this is all sort of in the same thing when something is off uh at least for me it doesn't look as nice and and a lot of the times it's just like lining things up nicely which is a small
它真的只是一套三四个简单的规则，而且，比如Bryce你提到的两个主要东西，在你的插件集中，是对齐，你知道，顶部、底部、左侧、右侧，然后还有垂直和水平间距，像这样的小东西，如果你有，我想我们甚至在你上次来的时候谈过这个，你有，比如，你知道五个项目符号，其中一个项目符号比其他的多出半行间距，那是不对称的。我认为我们的眼睛被吸引到对称性，因为它是模式识别，对我们的大脑来说更容易，哦，这都在同一个东西里，当某样东西偏离时，嗯，至少对我来说，它看起来没那么好。而且很多时候，它只是像把东西对齐得很好，这是一个小
thing but it can make a big difference well and, and also how you use space. If there's a dead space on your slide, if you're using all of your vertical space, but you've got huge amounts of dead space horizontally, just big blank regions, it just pains my heart. It pains my soul. And alignment's a difficult thing too, because it's what are the strong edges that your eye is attracted to and kind of understanding that. And in the case of text, you really want the baselines of your text to align. And when building UIs, that can get very complicated because you've got a button next to a pop-up or something, and those things have different heights. And as a developer frequently using an OS toolkit, you don't have control over where the OS is putting the text within those rectangles, but you really want to align the baselines between those two rectangles.
事情，但它可以产生很大的不同。嗯，还有，你如何使用空间。如果你的幻灯片上有死空间，如果你使用了所有的垂直空间，但你在水平方向上有大量的死空间，只是大的空白区域，这只会让我的心痛苦。这让我的灵魂痛苦。而且对齐也是一件困难的事情，因为它是你的眼睛被吸引到的强边缘，并且有点理解它。在文本的情况下，你真的希望文本的基线对齐。而在构建UI时，这可能会变得非常复杂，因为你有一个按钮在弹出窗口旁边之类的，而那些东西有不同的高度。作为一名经常使用操作系统工具包的开发人员，你无法控制操作系统将文本放在这些矩形内的什么位置，但你真的希望在两个矩形之间对齐基线。
Well, and you have to think about how it's going to align when it's localized, right? Yes, yes. And different languages have different rules. So things like, you know, Korean is, you know, centered aligned as opposed to baseline aligned. So, yeah, things like that are challenging when you're worried about building UI. Eve does some pretty nutty things to kind of make some of that stuff correct. it handles bizarre cases like a mix of left to right and right to right and right to left languages within the same UI and handling alignment across those two cases, which it turns out in some parts of the world is fairly common. Yeah. One thing that I probably spend
嗯，你必须考虑当它被本地化时它将如何对齐，对吧？是的，是的。不同的语言有不同的规则。所以像，你知道，韩语是，你知道，居中对齐，而不是基线对齐。所以，是的，当你担心构建UI时，像这样的事情是具有挑战性的。Eve做了一些相当疯狂的事情来使其中一些东西正确。它处理奇怪的情况，比如在同一个UI中混合从左到右和从右到左的语言，并处理跨这两个情况的对齐，事实证明在世界某些地方这是相当常见的。是的。有一件事我可能花
more time thinking about than I should is if I'm making a spreadsheet, how am I going to align the columns? Because if it's something like, you know, I think the left align for, you know, the rows of a table is probably like the most natural thing to me, just stylistically. I sort of think it's similar with like Sean said, like I don't necessarily have a good like reason for it, but it's just sort of like, you know, a gut, you know, a gut thing. It's sort of like natural language. Like might know that a way of phrasing something in English is not grammatically correct, but you can't name the particular rule for it. But if you left align numbers like currency, then it's harder to see the difference in magnitude between two different rows. And this is, I think, why Excel defaults to left alignment for text, but then right alignment for numbers. But then if you have some of your columns that are right aligned because they're numbers,
比我应该花的时间更多地思考，如果我正在制作电子表格，我将如何对齐列？因为如果它是像，你知道，我认为表格行的左对齐可能对我来说是最自然的事情，从风格上讲。我有点认为它类似于Sean说的，就像我并不一定有一个好的理由，但这只是某种，你知道，直觉，你知道，直觉的东西。它有点像自然语言。就像可能知道用英语表达某件事的方式在语法上是不正确的，但你无法说出它的特定规则。但如果你左对齐数字，比如货币，那么就更难看出两行之间数量级的差异。我认为这就是为什么Excel默认对文本进行左对齐，但对数字进行右对齐。但如果你有一些列因为是数字而右对齐，
and then others are text, and they're left like, should you right align all of them? What about the headers? Should those be centered? Should those be, you know, left aligned or right aligned? It's like I spend more time thinking about these things than I probably should. For numbers, that's a case where we borrowed numbers from Arabic. So they're Arabic numerals and hence they're right to left. Yeah. Excel is...
然后其他的是文本，它们是左对齐的，你应该把它们全部右对齐吗？标题呢？那些应该居中吗？那些应该，你知道，左对齐还是右对齐？就像我花在思考这些事情上的时间比我应该花的时间多。对于数字，那是我们从阿拉伯语借用数字的情况。所以它们是阿拉伯数字，因此它们是从右到左的。是的，Excel是……
I think they have a format for currency where it aligns the currency symbol and then right aligns the two decimal places and the decimal and the number. And so it figures out the maximum width of the integral part of your money amount. And that's my favorite, because that to me has the most symmetry, like all the decimals are lined up, all the money symbols of dollar sign or pound sign are all lined up. And then the only thing that's off is like when you have a, you know, $10 amount versus $100 amount, like you're going to have some empty space there. But like, for me, that's you can even like just sort of blur, squint your eyes and blur them. And like,
我想他们有一种货币格式，它对齐货币符号，然后右对齐两位小数、小数点和数字。所以它计算出你的金额整数部分的最大宽度。那是我的最爱，因为对我来说，那有最大的对称性，比如所有的小数点都对齐了，所有的美元符号或英镑符号都对齐了。然后唯一偏离的是，比如当你有一个，你知道，10美元的金额与100美元的金额时，比如你会在那里有一些空白空间。但比如，对我来说，那你可以甚至只是，你知道，眯起眼睛模糊它们。而且，比如，
you can see what the largest roughly what the largest amount is just by seeing which one is kicked out furthest to the left from the right this isn't even like a gooey problem you know as anybody who's ever tried to deal with uh padding um in uh with printf knows this is like not an easy not an easy thing to to clearly express it's one of the reasons why i'm so excited about std format um being in the c++ standard library because uh it's just such a better solution than the prior ones for doing something like i want i want this to be like padded in a certain way so that these things line up when I print them out in a for loop. Yeah, yeah. I like std format. It's still one of the things we had in ASL was a library for
你可以看到最大的，大致上最大的金额是多少，只要看哪一个从右边被踢到最左边。这甚至不是一个GUI问题，你知道，任何尝试过处理，嗯，填充，嗯，在，嗯，用printf的人都知道，这就像不是一个容易，不是一个容易清楚表达的事情。这也是我为什么对std format感到如此兴奋的原因之一，因为它在C++标准库中，因为，嗯，它只是比以前的解决方案好得多，可以做一些事情，比如我想要，我想要这个以某种方式填充，这样当我用for循环打印它们时，这些东西就会对齐。是的，是的。我喜欢std format。它仍然是我们ASL中拥有的东西之一，是一个用于
structured serialization. And that's one of the things that I think is still missing from C++. And at some point, I'd love to continue that work. But the idea with structured serialization is you format things based off the shape of the object. And so you have, is this thing a dictionary? Is it an array? Is it just an atom type, like just a number or just a string? And then once you have the structural information about what it is that you're printing, and that's all you need to describe to print something, then you can have a bunch of different back-end formatters. So you can say, well, output this structure as XML, output it as JSON,
结构化序列化的库。而且我认为这是C++中仍然缺失的东西之一。在某个时候，我很乐意继续这项工作。但结构化序列化的想法是，你根据对象的形状格式化东西。所以你有，这个东西是字典吗？它是数组吗？它只是原子类型，比如只是数字或只是字符串？然后一旦你有了关于你正在打印的东西的结构信息，而这就是你需要描述打印东西的全部，那么你就可以有一堆不同的后端格式化程序。所以你可以说，嗯，把这个结构输出为XML，输出为JSON，
output it as PDF as its own serialization format, output it as PDF. And so inside of the ASL, we have this concept of structured serialization. And so to use it, you just have to basically describe the shape of your objects, and then you can output them into any one of these formats. I actually do think that this is something that the C++ standard library will do eventually. And I think it's probably a good idea. And I think a design similar to what you just described will make a lot of sense too because while I'm not a huge fan of the idea of putting, say, a JSON or an XML library into standard C++, having some way of taking a representation of a C++ object and getting out JSON or XML
输出为PDF作为它自己的序列化格式，输出为PDF。所以，在ASL内部，我们有这个结构化序列化的概念。所以要使用它，你只需要基本上描述你的对象的形状，然后你就可以把它们输出到这些格式中的任何一种。我确实认为这是C++标准库最终会做的事情。而且我认为这可能是一个好主意。而且我认为类似于你刚才描述的设计也会很有意义，因为虽然我不是那种把，比如，JSON或XML库放入标准C++的想法的忠实粉丝，但有一种方法可以获取C++对象的表示并获取JSON或XML
would be really nice. And, you know, especially as we get, once we get reflection in the language, we'll be able to really build an excellent serialization facilities too. And so I think that's something, you know, in my CPAS was now keynote, I highlighted four priorities for the standard library. It was asynchrony and parallelism, IO, text processing, and metaprogramming and reflection. And I mean, that serialization really hits the IO and the metaprogramming reflection. And that serialization really hits the I.O. and the metaprogramming reflection. And I think it's going to be important in the future. I hope the Standards Committee takes an approach of being agnostic
会非常好。而且，你知道，特别是当我们得到，一旦我们在语言中有了反射，我们将能够真正构建出色的序列化设施。所以我认为这是，你知道，在我的C++ Now主题演讲中，我强调了标准库的四个优先事项。它是异步和并行、IO、文本处理以及元编程和反射。而且我的意思是，那个序列化确实触及了IO和元编程反射。而且那个序列化确实触及了I.O.和元编程反射。而且我认为它在未来会很重要。我希望标准委员会采取一种不可知论的方法
about the format of serialization and focusing on the structural aspects because if you look at, say, Objective-C has serialization, but it's in Apple's own format, proprietary format, and so the ones you move to say, well, I want to be able to serialize in JSON or XML, now you're on your own. And so it would be nice if C++ went the route of kind of being agnostic and being like, no, no, no, we're going to have an API that lets you plug in the actual formatter,
关于序列化的格式，并专注于结构方面，因为如果你看，比如Objective-C有序列化，但它是在苹果自己的格式中，专有格式，所以当你移动到说，好吧，我想要能够以JSON或XML序列化，现在你只能靠自己了。所以如果C++走那种不可知论的路线，比如，不，不，不，我们将有一个API让你插入实际的格式化程序，那会很好，
and we're just going to have a standard way to describe the structural information. Yeah. And that's a very C++-y way to do things. Like I like to say that the thing that makes C++ C++ is this idea of universality, that C++ doesn't in C++, there usually is no one right answer. The right answer is to support whatever the right solution is for each individual domain. Thanks for listening. Tune in next week for an epic part two. Have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且我们将只有一种标准方式来描述结构信息。是的。这是一种非常C++的方式来做事情。就像我喜欢说的，让C++成为C++的东西是这种普遍性的想法，C++在C++中，通常没有一个正确的答案。正确的答案是支持每个单独领域所需的正确解决方案。感谢收听。下周请收听史诗般的第二部分。祝你有美好的一天。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。